In this video, we're going to add a sound cue to our level in order to be able to play background music.
There are a couple different ways we can work with audio files inside of Unreal,
but the simplest way is to place a sound cue actor into a level that will play a specific audio file.
These assets also allow you to specify attenuation settings like falloff and reverb and a million other things.
We are going to be placing a sound cue that is included with the starter content.
There we go. Audio, we can see a list here.
Lots of different explosions, but we are going to pick starter music one.
And so we can see here that they've already included a starter music sound cue for us.
We can drag that into our level. I'll put that up a little higher.
We'll go back to selection mode and look at our details.
And we can see we're going to have our volume set to one.
Attenuation, we're just going to use defaults. We're not going to worry with creating a custom setting for that.
Now when we press play, we hear our music.
One thing to note, though, is that Unreal is also currently switching over to the new high performance procedural audio engine meta sounds.
So you might be seeing more and more of that as you explore working with audio inside of Unreal going forward.
In the next video, we'll look at how we can package our game into an executable that other people can install.